this guy nadal
just won the australian open out in
melbourne australia right there okay and
he's celebrating
post match and basically he went to
celebrate they gave him champagne to
celebrate and he spit it out
he spit it out he goes no no no i'm not
drinking i haven't drank in four months
and that is part of the reason why i
have this success right here so yo
respect to him for not drinking and that
brought up a thing to me like
i once went i don't know the longest i
think i went six months without drinking
six months now i think that was a while
ago
um
maybe the longest time i've gone without
a drink
is
maybe a month these days do you guys
have any strong feelings on drinking not
drinking i know we wanted to take a shot
before the show jenny said no i do
that's not happening i'm actually glad
you brought this up because i was in a
miami club this weekend and at a table
and guys kept being like hey can i get
your drink i'm like i'm good you don't
drink no i i'm just i'm good
and they're like the more you tell
people that you're not drinking the more
insecure they become people can't fathom
the idea of being out and just being
comfortable being yourself dance is my
drug when i go out i go out to dance and
the more sober i am the more fun i am
the more fun i have because i'm
comfortable with myself i don't need
liquid courage i got enough courage
liquid actually makes me less sure of
myself it makes me uh
more loose and not in a good way
okay like i i don't like the decisions i
make i don't like
driving under the any kind of influence
in miami there's no public
transportation you have to drive or take
a 50 uber i rather not drink my night is
going to be better if i don't drink wow
always so what's the longest you've gone
without drinking i don't even take
you don't drink i don't really
no i just don't
free alcohol
if it's there fine like i'll drink it
but i don't like drinking at all i like
sugar so cocktails are nice but you know
you'd rather have chocolate
if the bar handed out chocolate i'd be
so dumb but you're gonna get yourself a
mom bond you don't want that no okay
she'll dance it off i will there dance
is my drug respect to you it is you i
mean you're not a big drinker
i love wine okay
red wine you're a run one kind of girl
white wine all right red wine at night
white during the day sometimes jose
depending on the occasion love my wine
okay and i do drink
but
for fun off of radars not when i'm
working
okay cool but i'm saying when you're out
in clubs yeah i drink yeah
do you drink and get drunk
i drink and i get drunk and do you like
do you have more fun when you're drunk
it's just a different experience
okay like i'm the girl that i go out to
dance right like i am on the dance floor
yeah give me the music video on the
dance floor by myself i don't care if
somebody i am the same and it's cool
because lately like a lot of women come
and they want to dance to them oh she's
having such a great time like i want to
join that yeah so you're making it
acceptable for women to come and just
let loose and not feel not feel like
they're judged because you're not
judging yourself right yeah so sometimes
i'm not gonna lie alcohol does let me
get a little more loose and feel like oh
not everybody's like watching me right
so i can like be more of myself you know
which is something i'm working on right
in in my personal journey of self-growth
like being able to just do that without
anything right but it does it does it
does uh calm me down a little bit like
if i have a drink it'll calm me down a
little bit to just be like all right
let's go live your life girl hey
what about what about um drinking too
much and making some bad decisions oh
listen done that been there done that
never mind what like would you share
some of that
i think you should go to emma and then
come back to me so i can think about it
yo listen i have never been the girl
people had to take care of me never in
my life okay i've never been that girl
and i've i've taken care of so many that
it gives me anxiety when i'm around
girls that are really drunk when i see
them
i get really anxious i don't like it i
don't like being in clubs and seeing
that girl and her friends are trying to
pick her up and the bouncer and she's
puking on herself it gives me so much
anxiety i hate it so that's why i never
let myself get that well in miami like
you brought this up amber look
in the nightlife business
if there's 10 um tables in the club
let's just say probably seven of them
are paying and three are free right the
promoters have tables they're bringing
the pretty girls the girls come in save
that money they're not paying for drinks
drink all you want get as toasty as you
want you're gonna hang out the promoters
and those are the girls they're not
paying for tables they're not paying for
anything they tend to get very
sloppy listen i was at the club this
weekend and i've never seen so many
people try so hard and not have a good
time like i don't think anybody's having
a good time you have like 50 girls
packed into one booth they can't move
then nobody's approaching you how could
somebody approach you you're like third
what club are you at no fandom
and and the best one is this
yes um
cocktail on one hand phone in the other
and they're like this when did we come
out to be on social media yeah come out
so that you know if you don't document
the time you're at the club where you
even have to be the best the best
moments are when they're not documented
100 right so speak about these best
moments of when you were drunk and go
ahead jenny what story comes to mind of
maybe a bad decision or two you made
because you were too drunk um
[Music]
i think growing up when i was younger
living in the industry i was the vegan
um
i didn't know how to differentiate work
from play and which is why i'm so big on
it now
so
being in that i was maybe drinking in
environments
where my judgment
wasn't always the best and it gave room
for
things to happen
you know so now i'm very big on like if
i'm working i'm working and that's it
but if i'm on my free time with my
friends with my girlfriends like going
out having fun
that's a different story so you draw a
line you draw a line where you say
yeah but i'm also somebody that i don't
get drunk and get like sloppy like i get
drunk and some people don't even know
i'm drunk
let me tell you like i'm one of those
people like i'm always like
i'm sorry
she's like she's just very quiet right
i'm here i i actually respect what
you're saying right now because i was
actually just at a business conference
down in miami's thing at the trump doral
and i go to a business conference once a
month let's say right
and growing up in miami in the nightlife
business
i've again spent
many and many and many times drunk
wasted all that partying drink or
whatever so when i go to these business
conferences sometimes they're in dallas
sometimes they're atlanta some they're
all over the country i'm going to one in
charleston south carolina next month
and
we go and there's all these business
guys successful guys a little bit older
at least in in the financial services
insurance business
all of them i'm not saying all of them
but people who are kind of like trying
to get away they are drinking
they are they they're like they
basically are like look i've got three
days away from my wife and kids i'm
about to tear up charleston i'm about to
tear up dallas because they don't they
need it that's my point and then they
come to me because i'm obviously you
know the one of the younger cooler guys
in in this industry
and they're like adam let's go bro we're
hitting the town you're coming with us
to strip club i'm like
bro no i'm good like i'm here for three
days to crush it in business and then if
i want to get tipsy turvy topside i'll
just do it in south beach in miami i'm
not i don't need to hang out with you
know 40 like literally 40 60 year old
men to go rip it up in dallas it's just
not a good look so i do i do appreciate
what you're saying is that i can
distinguish between business and
pleasure and if it's a business trip i'm
focusing on
business like last night
i was staying at the trump hotel i'm
getting texts from the guys yo bro we're
at the bar where you at i'm like dude
i'm in my hotel room 10 o'clock
like getting ready for the pvd podcast
in the morning i like i don't have 30's
i don't need to hang out with you guys
and and shoot the [ __ ] no but
like to you said they get three days to
get away and this is like their escape
to just rip it up
away from the wife away from the kids
and a lot of some some of these guys and
this is what like the
the the the secret elephant in the room
as you start to drink your inhibitions
start to go
you kind of maybe take your ring off
right maybe you start to get away
exactly you start to maybe i don't know
it's not a big deal
you blame it on the eye
you know talk about work in my industry
comedians we often get paid in drinks
drink tickets that's literally how i get
paid and so 100
and i i hate it because you're just mo i
guess some comedians need a little drink
to get on stage not me any kind of any
kind of influence will be like
uh debilitating for me and my set but
that's it's in my world so much every
night comedians go out three or four
times hustle they're drinking five five
times a week
and there's no separation you have to
because then you're like what else well
like this is how i'm getting paid so i
might as well take advantage yes
and yeah it's creating bad habits early
i never feel
great after drinking i mean like wow
that was amazing by the way you bring up
a good point when i i got out of the
night life cuz i used to do stand-up
comedy at the
just everywhere ever you know the places
down there
um i would get paid in drink tickets at
the club
drink tickets at the comedy club
and get paid occasionally in laughs if i
did a good joke time you know
and i was like i'm sick of getting paid
in laughs and drink tickets i got to
figure out a way to make some money like
what you did and look what i did now i
got my own financial show talking about
getting drunk but i just think drinking
is so socially acceptable it's so much
worse than some of the other uh drugs
out there that you can choose to you
know whatever turn yourself down i think
people like to drink because it like for
some people it turns them up for me it
turns me down okay in terms of my energy
and my like vibes some people they need
that but like drinking for the amount of
people that have died
and things that bad have happened and
you become addicted to alcohol and
becomes liver problems and becomes
behavioral problems and then that gets
transferred in the portal to the next
kid that is ongoing
[Music]